hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to blank dream now where we
last left off we just kind of cleared
this area here and the painter had a
good time with the paint that we got him
and oh we're probably going to another
mirror up here sorry I could have just
gone up this way before hello the mirror
shows mashiro's reflection look in I
wonder what happy memory we're gonna
trigger this time because last ones
weren't exactly the greatest a secret
base what does that even mean a month
ago getting closer to the presents oddly
oddly enough hello hey mashiro welcome
to my Atelier err at Le air it's just a
shack that you've decided as yours come
on of course I'll leave if any manager
type comes along and tells me to but I
can't paint at home so I'm hoping they
can let it slide your mom hates art
right yeah I don't exactly know why but
my mom gets really angry when I paint so
I have to paint outside in secret yeah
it's that scary that's kind of absurd
but I won't question it very much
because I think you're cute that's what
that seems so strange since you're
pretty good at yato art is nice you can
create any world you imagine on a white
canvas without really reality keeping
you down things that aren't real or that
are gone now they can all live within
art I had an older sister you know had
yeah not anymore I guess it was seven
years ago now the girl's body was found
in Mirror Lake
they concluded it was murder from the
state of the body but never did catch
any criminal I will admit you kind of do
look like the blond girl in the place
but then again a lot of exam may draw
characters look kind of the same and yes
that girl was my sister and the day I
met you and Mirror Lake was the day of
her death so after visiting her grave I
went to the lake so that was it and so
well how do you put this a girl there
all alone who in my mind reminded me so
much my sister I had to call out
huh you mean me yeah apparently my
sister used to stare into mirror lake
from time to time you both have a
similar blunt attitude never smile as if
nothing amuses you feels like you're
insulting me look it's true so actually
I have a request Mashiro I'll get
straight to the point
will you model for me oh my goodness I
thought you'd never ask
model for a painting yeah I want to
preserve the traces of my sister I can
see in you in a painting it'd be great
if I could give me a nice smile too not
a chance
I've never smiled since the war I
thought so well I won't ask you to just
sit there it's fine if you just let me
consult your face while I draw I guess
that's fine Thanks it'll really help
I'm sure it's fate that I met you my
sister in my memory and you right now I
want to paint those two things together
do you do what you want this is
embarrassing it sure is it's so
embarrassing that for some reason I'm
gonna find some way to end my life now
which is horrible
lined with photo albums and books of
paintings I otto's treasured collection
I'm gonna do everything double because I
found something else double before the
drab shelves are full of art supplies
and materials just using jacket seems
okay word there won't you try painting
Mashiro zero like a white canvas it's a
wonderful name I hate it it makes it
sound like there's nothing to me I see
you really do have my sister's
personality maybe I am your long-lost
sister
art supplies art supplies bottles of
unfamiliar substance was one of them
blood and one was one of them horrible
black substance oh that it's sort of a
memento of my sister I don't generally
like stuffed animals so you should give
it some love Monsieur oh okay all righty
then
a fire extinguisher seems pretty old the
deteriorated fire extinguishers at risk
of exploding oh okay
if it explodes it'll impact your face
it's really dangerous you know the face
that a yatta wants to paint over there
uh is there nothing else here that I
need believe I've tried everything okay
I guess that's it then here we go oh boy
the oldest fire extinguisher exploded
directly impacting mashiro's face oh my
face why oh man okay welp that's no
mirror down goody goody gumdrops I'm so
happy
glad that that happened alrighty then
back in this world a-okay Mashiro came
to against standing before the mirror
though she felt like her bones broken
from the explosion there wasn't even a
scratch on her face yes after I'm eating
a mirror like a yacht oh and I
occasionally met and that day at a
secret base I heard about his sister and
became his model this person a yacht Oh
had a great significance to me right so
why did she throw herself in the lake
then something bad must have happened I
don't know Justin Michelle regained a
piece of her memory she felt as if she'd
lost something important yeah that that
keeps happening I'm pretty sure that's
not gonna end well for me cuz like most
of these RPG horror Maker games I'm
pretty sure there's got to be some sort
of a secret ending that
hi Jesus don't do that to me
I don't even think I got another key did
I I don't think so hi deep in the realms
huh I always wanted to stay away from
even spirits does that stuff bother you
Monsieur oh okay okay uh I think there
must be another bronze door that I can
open up without that assistance so it
was at the bottom maybe yeah okay here
we go
unlock the door with the bronze key all
right what's going oh hi how's it going
there friend
Bonjour Madame Maduro me will you be
attending the crack smile dinner party
Madame oh why yes I see but Madame your
face is too stiff from the crook for the
crack smile but in a party if you insist
on attending perhaps used to find the
smiling soul and work on your smile oh
that sounds so delightful I just had my
face exploded by a fire extinguisher
does that count okay here we go glad
we're here me daughter doe me sigh I
want something sweet huh you want to
meet the smiling soul there in the air
but I won't let you in for free it's my
turf you don't have anything to offer
how about our knife douche okay fine
yeah play the sound of the iron smirk
but know that a performance with no one
seated is worthless oh okay okay right
normal hello I need to like statue hello
baby a pumpkin wearing a wits like cat
the sweet smell wafts out of its carved
eyes how about a knife Mashiro swung the
knife down on the pumpkin thunk took no
real damage
great why is there blood everywhere
why Oh what did i do what did i do what
did I do wrong
what did i do right okay apparently
don't engage the pumpkin until I'm ready
to smash it open maybe a hammer or
something hi
whoa okay you little [ __ ] okay thank
you very much
I knew there was something wrong about
that doll I just didn't think it would
push me into the pit of death I should
be on the more I should be more on the
lookout for everything here don't trust
anything I swear this has more traps
than like the witch's house did those a
lot of things than Wits just house that
I didn't explore what dolls casually
sitting there okay small hammers I'll
take one of those thank you very much
silver door is locked guard that means
I'm going to get hurt not a light on how
do I smash you bad funk harder than
expected it doesn't seem like it'll
break I'll crap it's gonna kill me it's
gonna kill me
oh come on okay oh maybe I gotta hit it
from the back I think that's what I
gotta do no damn it
nice oh crap oh oh god okay alright well
that did not work out I'm so glad that
this is an adventure that I had I'm
doing so good in this realm of dreams
I can't wait to die some more alright so
maybe maybe smashy-smashy isn't exactly
what I should be going for here that
donal is just soaked I know it's only
like a few pixels but it's so creepy hi
what's going on here oh uh okay hey
Mookie okey okay alrighty then I guess
I'll just be on my way
apparently I'm not supposed to smash
nothing Wolke dokey then why am I in the
realm of love this does not seem like
the realm of love won't open Oh goddamn
it
what am I supposed to do what about four
oh oh oh oh maybe I'm maybe I'm an idiot
maybe I'm not supposed to smash it at
all maybe I'm supposed to light it up
with the lantern
nope apparently not I'll just die okay
alrighty then good so what am I supposed
to do
maybe I'm supposed to smash this guy in
the face maybe that's what it is okay
hammer no oh nice no I already do that
lantern crap I'm lost again
oh boy okay well no hello what are you
doing you want to get all the sounds
like me whoa okay so am I supposed to do
doremi okay I got it
okay so I'm supposed to hit don't Raimi
and order doh
[ __ ] ray me did I do that wrong
hello Hatter help okay come with me
with me a little more now sit on the
thing sit on the thing I'm gonna play a
nice no no no no no no come on come on
come on come on come on come on go be
silly oh come on come on come on to know
the dang ol Ted oh the Tang pattern
Holloway Holloway damn it come on
we're doing
okay don't follow me now get ready for a
dull ramie like you've never heard
before go right hey I supposedly what
are you doing oh there we go there we go
got it got okay got it got it got it
stay right there stay right there stay
right there no rye hey did I do it I do
it some of the iron smirk ray me go
oh there you got it ok well alrighty
then there was a loud sound somewhere
did you like that did you enjoy my
performance did you enjoy it
good glad you did creepy ass doll I know
what the hell you think you're up to oh
wow what the hell happened
pieces of the pumpkin in a bag of candy
are spilling out from the ceiling okay
god Candy's loss squishy squishy squishy
why so squishy okay so I got the candy
so I should be able to turn this into
the person and see this okay oh this is
not what it was oh this oh I was now
ready I was not ready I was now ready I
was not ready okay okay I see oh there's
gonna be your son of a [ __ ]
alrighty want revenge for whatever the
hell I did to you
I'd do anything me whoo okay all right
okay here we go
oh yes oh yes oh yes that looked like
the hallway where I cut up the painting
maybe I just did a bad thing I thought
things are supposed to be the realm of
love all right so anyway that's all the
time I have for this episode here I
really hope you're enjoying this game
because it's awesome in a lot of ways
thank you again everybody and as always
I will see you in the next video
- Jung scores by themselves are often
pretty crappy